[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Sushant Singh he is here at Yale as a
visiting scholar and the counsel on
South Asian Studies and the Department
of Political Science mr. Singh is the
deputy editor of the Indian Express
newspaper in Delhi India where he writes
about national security international
relations higher judiciary and
investigative agencies among other
places
he has reported about conflict from
North Waziristan in Pakistan and from
the afghanistan/pakistan border before
turning to journalism he served in the
Indian Army for 20 years including
multiple stints in Jammu and Kashmir he
also served as a United Nations military
observer
in Cote d'Ivoire where he was awarded
the UN Secretary General's medal he is
the author of mission overseas daring
operations by the Indian military and
the co-author of note by note the Indian
story 1947 to 2017 today we'll talk with
mr. Singh about the conflict between
India and Pakistan over Kashmir welcome
mr. Singh thank you so much so let's
talk about the conflict between India
and Pakistan over Kashmir it's been
going on for just about 70 years at this
point so tell him tell us about it so
the conflict in Kashmir actually started
when India was under British colonial
rule and the British colonial masters
decided to leave India and they decided
to split India between India and
Pakistan that happened in the year 1947
so besides the colonial India and
colonial Pakistan those 12 territories
which were ruled by the British by the
British government at that point in time
there were certain independent states
certain princely states which had a
shared sovereignty with the British
masters and their very limited self-rule
kind of a thing
Kashmir was one of these princely states
they were around seven
of them you know ranging from very small
areas of a few square few square miles
to really big ones like Kashmir Kashmir
the muslim-majority region Pakistan was
formed for the Muslims of South Asia now
where is India said that it's a secular
republic for all religions so both both
countries wanted - me to be part of to
be part of their country Modi
government's wanted them to be part of
the country Pakistan said because it's
Muslim majority therefore should be
within Pakistan India said we don't
believe all people all kinds of people
are here Christians Hindus in Muslims
there are six Parsi so we know it's
perfectly fine if Kashmir this part is
part of us so the the decision came upon
Kashmir's maharaja who was a Hindu he
decided to join India as Pakistan
Pakistani supported tribals attack
attack attack Kashmir and then this led
to a war between India and Pakistan in
1948 so didn't certain territories were
occupied by Pakistan the rest of the
territories almost 2/3 of the territory
is is with India including the major
inhabited areas of Kashmir Valley which
is which is the region everybody or
everybody covets
there been further the UN brought in a
ceasefire in 1949 and the and there was
a ceasefire line which is now on all of
the line of control between the two
sites within the within the Kashmir
Valley they've been they've been to
other wars over Kashmir in 1965 and in
1999 unlimited war in Kargil region
between between between India and
Pakistan and there's been while these
people decided to join India in 1947
supported by the tallest leader in the
last 30 years
from 1989 onwards there's been an
insurgency in Kashmir which is which
believes that it is not getting its due
from India and they would want some kind
of referendum some kind of what they
were used the word Azadi or freedom from
from India and put that to decide their
own fate India has pushed in a large
amount of security forces it has brought
the violence down in in Kashmir but a
political resolution has not been found
found so far and the situation room a
continues to remain raita let's talk
about the situation today I mean it's
it's really just come to a boil again
recently so let's talk a little bit
about that the situation currently has
come to a boil if you know just to step
back if you look at look at Jammu and
Kashmir it is primarily three regions
there in the Jambo region which is the
focus of the Himalayans
the Kashmir region which is a valley
which is
the muslim-dominated area and the most
beautiful area I'm almost like
Switzerland in some ways and you go up
north there's the Ladakh region which is
a dry cold dry cold desert the whole is
the whole dispute is about the Kashmir
is about the Kashmir Valley and in the
Kashmir Valley as I said there were
there's been in surgeon c4 for last 30
years and when Kashmir excited to India
in 1947 it exceeded through an
instrument called article 370 article 37
zero which actually specified that it
was a limited merger with India you know
it had a special status in the in the in
the in the Indian state India as a
unitary Strait unlike the United States
which is a federal state so you have a
unitary state we have these various
various are the constituents but they
don't have real independence in that
sense but Kashmir had a state special
status one last month the current Indian
government which is a Hindu majoritarian
government of the party gentle party
they decided that a Muslim majority
state should not have this patient
status and through a legal deviously
legal legal mechanism a very complicated
legal mechanism they removed this
special status and you know that 370 has
been removed and that really caused a
lot of turmoil and anguish because they
believe that even this fig leaf or first
patient status which Kashmir had has
been taken away moreover while it
earlier it was a state now they have
made it up they split it into two and
made it a federally administered
territory you know it's no longer an
independent state it will be controlled
directly by the by the central
government in Delhi because it is
happening in the context of a Hindu
majoritarian government ruling in ruling
in in Delhi essentially ruling India at
this point in time
whereas Kashmir is a Muslim majority
region and so this has led to a lot of
angst turmoil there's been curfew
imposed the mobile communication has
been shut down internet has been shut
down for last 52 days there's no mobile
telephony there's no internet there's no
business going on it is media the news
local newspapers are publishing just
four-page copies so it has been it has
been very tough and you know it is
pretty bad the situation both are a
humanitarian level as well as at a
political level in Kashmir doesn't look
good at this moment so the people of
Kashmir are they trying to leave at this
point at all are they you know trying to
come into India because of the
difficulty if they don't have
you know the necessary services there
what is happening in that regard so
people of Kashmir it--not would want
certain kind of normalcy to return in
fact the government of India would want
a certain kind of normalcy to return but
there is so much of anguish and anger
among the people at what has been done
to them and done to them in a very
serious manner done to them you know by
a sleight of hand in a in a in a way so
they are they're pretty angry about it
so it's almost what they call a civil
curfew a curfew imposed by the people
themselves so they will open shops only
for a couple of hours and won't open of
course they would want business to
return to normalcy internet to come in
you know all the other services that are
available should come in but it but the
government of India is not giving in
because they're really worried there
could lead to protest violence and all
kinds of situation which would show
India in a very bad light especially
when the Indian Prime Minister is in the
United States attending the United
Nations General Assembly or doing events
with President Trump etc it will not
give a good impression of India at that
time and let's talk about President
Trump he was recently in the news as
trying to broker a deal between the two
countries what is your take on that
so president Trump has maintained this
for a long period of time for last few
weeks more than a couple of months that
he would like to broker a deal between
India and Pakistan
and this is a this is a statement which
he has made again and again even when
the Pakistani Prime Minister Mehran Khan
has met him a couple of times all the
Indian Prime Minister has met him a
couple of times so even otherwise in
other for us he has very clearly
articulated his desire that he could
actually bring peace and and win a Nobel
Peace Prize for doing this yet he has
actually said that very loud very loud
and clear now the problem is India has
since 1971 when India defeated Pakistan
to create the independent country of
Bangladesh India has always believed
that Kashmir or any other dispute
between India and Pakistan in the
bilateral dispute it is not something
which will be discussed multilaterally
over the other countries Pakistan of
course would want the issue to be
discussed meant literally because if
that would put pressure on India
Pakistan being a smaller country cannot
put that pressure on India on its own so
India is very clear that they do not
want mediation they would they would not
want President Trump to mediate but
whereas Pakistan would want President
Trump to mediate the president Trump
initially he said you know both the
countries want me to mediate but later
on he has modified a statement and ad
caveat he said I am ready to mediate I
would love to mediate but both countries
have to request me to mediate but both
countries clearly India is not going to
request him or India not only even agree
to to president Trump mediating so I see
it is a no-go although it does make
India's position slightly difficult and
it's but it's likely embarrassing for
the Indian Prime Minister Prime Minister
Modi and China also has a role to play
in this as well are they bringing any
pressure to bear on a situation yeah
well China of course continues to be a
continues to be strongly allied to
Pakistan and you know so it has issued a
statement along with Pakistan and trying
to try to bring some some some pressure
on India but more importantly there's a
portion of of the erstwhile state of
Jammu and Kashmir princely state of
Jammu and Kashmir which is with China
the oxygen area from which the Karakoram
highway runs etc that is that has been
taken over by China anything and in
China and India went to a war over it
over it in 1962 in which China thrashed
India defeated India and so there's a
portion of portion of Kashmiri which is
with China as well and through that
portion the the Pakistan does Pakistan
and China connected wire highway which
is called the Karakoram highway so it is
strategically important it also connects
the two countries it and it ends circles
in it encircles India India would want
China and Pakistan both to leave the
Jammu and Kashmir region but very
clearly the power differential between
India and China is such that it that
India cannot really force the Chinese
and Chinese have issued very strong
statements on what the Indian government
recently did in Kashmir on article 370
it issued very strong statement and it
said you know this alters our status quo
which has been done and India said no we
are not altering the status quo this is
an internal administrative measure so
please don't take it that way that that
way and the Chinese president is going
to be in in the next couple of weeks
he's going to be in India for an
informal summit President Xi so it's
quite a complicated situation and China
is trying to put pressure but I don't
know how much of the pressure would work
on India so what do you think actually
needs to happen for everything to work
out that's that you know I probably I
would get the Nobel Prize if I were to
answer that question
see Kashmir is a conflict not just over
territory it's a conflict over a
national ID
these sub-national identities religious
identities no economic resources you
know and so many other historical
factors you know now it's a battle of
narratives and there are multiple
narratives over which Kashmir is being
Kashmir is being for the very simple
answer logical answer which has always
been proposed would be to make this line
of control which is now for last 70
years more than 70 years first January
14 1949 onwards make this line of
control as a de facto international
border and the part of Kashmir which is
with Pakistan can remain with Pakistan
and the part of Kashmir which is with
India can remain with India and they can
both sides can now live happily ever
after after 71 years but clearly that
would not satisfy either of the country
because Pakistan wants cash made to
complete the project for Muslims of
South Asia that Muslims of Muslim
majority region should not be with India
whereas India has always believed as
part of a secular India it needs some
Muslim it needs a Muslim state but now
with the Hindu majority in government in
in power in India it becomes more more
difficult and more complicated what do
the people of Kashmir want the Kashmir
people of Kashmir essentially if you
strip it down to the basics is they say
they we want freedom as adi that you
know the slogan is Azadi we want freedom
and if translated freedom you know can
be translated in many ways independence
freedom whatever but essentially it's
about they should be able to or they
want the freedom to choose
they want their what they say you know
we were promised a referendum by the
United Nations and there were certain
conditions before a referendum could
have been done
we were never offered that referendum
whether we want to go with India or with
Pakistan I want to become independent
historically some of the most powerful
Kashmiri leaders have talking about
creating an independent state but that
clearly now seems to be seems to be out
of question so the demand is for Azadi
or freedom or independence whichever way
you would call it and I think the
freedom is to say that give us a
referendum give us a choice you allow us
to exercise a choice to desert to do
what we want to what we want to do it's
not really that they they love pakistan
anymore there is a state in which
pakistan is there it's not a pakistan is
an attraction so it is more and more we
see a lot of people a lot of young
people talking about some kind of
independent or quasi independent status
for kashmir as a state or the country so
kashmir basically wants to be
independent
it's sounding why is that not possible
is there something if that Kashmir has
that Pakistan and India want other than
just a geographic region as I said it's
a question of national identity for both
the cup for both the countries he is the
most some the muslim-majority region for
India it's a secular republic it would
want it Pakistan would wanted as a
Muslim as a Muslim Islamic country but
also its location it is located
Afghanistan China India Pakistan Central
Asia so you know it's a it's a vase
strategically located area through which
I know you can actually control and
everybody believes if Kashmir were to be
made independent even for a limited
portion it would be gobbled up by one of
the major countries you know it would it
cannot really it would be a country like
Bhutan or Nepal and it would it would
have to be protracted of one of the
bigger neighbours and it has no access
to see so no lie Afghanistan it would
have huge problems you know we will do
trade from it won't have seed you know
access to sea
so it's geographically while it is a it
is a bigger area this location and it's
you know and and no access to see etc no
real economy in that sense of production
etc would make it very difficult for it
to exist independently on its own right
so how do you think this all will end up
I mean if they do not reach some kind of
an agreement you know what will be the
result of that see the result currently
seems to be pretty messy it will
continue to be this kind of you know
unresolved mess we are not looking at a
solution so so quickly in Kashmir
I think the current Indian government
believes that it can tire out the
Kashmiris and they will come back to
some kind of they will reconcile to
their fate and be kind and reconcile to
this new the to this new reality whereas
the Pakistan is raising it
internationally and Kashmiri this will
probably rise up again maybe take guns
maybe do some violence but we do some
street protests so I see a I see a
period of great instability with no
answers coming in and that is coming in
for various factors one is the nature of
the Indian government that is there
today
which is clearly not very accommodative
in nature which is like a you know very
majoritarian in a certain way in sp
approach and that would make it very
difficult to find a common ground where
it would go out and say you know kill
can we talk and can we can we concede
something so the idea is not to concede
anything
idea is to subjugate and subdue so
clearly I see a lot of oppression a lot
of separation and some kind of
international attention coming in from
Kashmir and this will it doesn't be a
good fortune for Kashmiri or for the
Kashmiri Xindi in India near future it
is going to be pretty tough well that is
unfortunate to hear and you know
hopefully something will change to
affect some kind of result there that
they could be happy with hopefully I
also I also hope that the people of
Kashmiri essentially more than anybody
else the people of Kashmir who should
not suffer and they should find some
solution which brings peace and harmony
to the right right very good thank you
for talking about this with us today I
appreciate you being here thank you so
much for calling me here thank you for
more information about mr. Singh please
visit our website at macmillan report
that yelled at edu be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at you
you